our first guest oh my gosh is an
activist a philanthropist and the author
of a new book book that exploded
in popularity the day it came out okay
this is my copy it's been on the new
york times bestseller list
for 31 weeks in a row and some of its
devoted fans are people you may have
heard of like
reese witherspoon and
kristen bell oh chelsea handler
mandy moore and
the book is called untamed
and i actually found out about it
because
i was looking at adele's instagram and
the way that she worded it
i knew that i had to run out that day to
the bookstore and buy it and start
reading it
so i am honored to say that the author
is here
please welcome glennon doyle
hello hi drew how are you
i feel like i'm meeting with the
mind and heart that is created this
incredible movement and you are
striking a chord with people
that is really large unusual
important it's a wave we're all getting
incredibly swept up in it
but when things are so popular
and zeitgeisty and collective experience
i either wanted to have a ton of humor
because i need that
which your book does you have you're so
witty but i want it to have depth and
meaning
and this is so incredible
you are changing people's lives i mean
adele literally said
i'm living a new life after i've read
this book
why did you write this book well
drew um i found myself in kind of a
busted up marriage
to a good man which is a hard place to
be because women are supposed to be
grateful for what we have
um and in the midst of all of that of
trying to heal the marriage i fell
madly in love with a woman and when i
saw her this
self rose up in me that i recognized as
the self i was before the world told me
who to be
and it really felt like a life or death
situation am i going to honor this self
and really rock the boat or am i going
to abandon myself again
um and instead i decided to abandon
everyone else's expectations of me
and to follow that love with abby and
what i found
drew is that sometimes we have to go
outside of the world's expectations and
ideals for us
to find a love and a family and a faith
and a nation in a world that doesn't
require us to abandon ourselves anymore
and revolution happens when women stop
abandoning themselves
i mean this is what my copy of the book
looks
like it's like i don't know if you can
see that but
every single line is almost annotated on
a page
there are phrases and sentences that you
say
and uh we're filming a time management
segment
and there was this amazing book i know
how she does it where she breaks down
the time in life to an excel spreadsheet
and there was so much less time
in life than i would have guessed as a
pisces who has no concept
of numbers and time are you a pisces
yes yes i think in colors oh okay this
explains a lot
i i
we need guides when books become really
important and they become of movement
it's because they are
speaking about what and how to do
the what is something we all grapple
with the how
is something we all need and your book
is about the how
and i must say that the relevancy of
this year
and the understanding of
we have finite time here on this earth
we are trapped by societal
you know boxes we are supposed to check
and the guilt
of not following them and what does that
do
does that have us live a life for
someone or something else
and your book i've never read anything
quite like it where it explains
how to be aware of that which we are all
fighting inside it's like you found our
inner voices and given them a megaphone
that's what reading your book feels like
but then it has the how
it has action but i feel like the person
that's screaming inside of all of us
reads this book and goes oh my gosh
there is so much value
in asking ourselves what is the true
life we want to live and how do we go
about doing that
did you intend to do that when you are
writing it
i mean i just was i was trying to give
voice and life to the self
inside that felt trapped beneath you
know the ideals and expectations
that we have for women and i think i
started um recovering that
self in sobriety you know i think it
started for me
when i got sober at 25 years old and i
sat down next to a woman at a recovery
meeting and i said life is so hard and i
feel like
everyone else has some sort of secret to
being human that i don't have
because it feels so much harder for me
than it looks for everyone else
and she said the secret of life
is not that it feels hard for you
because you're doing it wrong it feels
hard because you're finally doing it
right
right that that being human is hard
and and and sitting with uncomfortable
feelings and not numbing them is hard
that's one of the things in your book
that means so much to me is
you're speaking of and if you're in
cognitive therapy or
you know anyone who embraces embracing
the pain
and the discomfort because we are all
doing everything whether it's on our
phone
or having a drink or eating food or
talking even to someone just about it
but not really
like you know getting to the bottom of
it we are all
desperate to avoid the pain and
discomfort and the way
that you help us get excited about it
is so actionable and you've gotten sober
you've found a whole new life path
i find that if you are talking about big
ticket items
this is the book for you if you are
talking about small
changes this is the book for you if you
are talking about how to get
in touch with your truth and your inner
voice this is the book for you
i mean you are setting people free and i
can't thank you
enough for my experience
with this book and it's so personal and
by the way you are the best
funniest wittiest writer ever and i'm
not you deserve
awards everywhere for your style of
writing and your wording
it has poetry it's sexy it's liberating
you
are just my hero and i can't believe i
actually got to talk to you and i'm all
my friends texting me jealous
that i'm getting to talk to you so thank
you glenn and doyle
untamed the new york times best-selling
book
the liberation the beauty the poetry
thank you so much glennon for coming on
this show
drew thank you and i just want to say
one thing to you
you you and your team are doing such a
beautiful job with this show my favorite
art is art that is particular to the
artist and is also about all of us
and that's what you are doing with the
show it feels like it's about all of us
every single day just
i know it's not easy keep going you are
doing it sister you are doing it
i trust in you thank you for telling me
that i will carry that with me
and that's exactly what i want people to
do with the show carry it with you the
humor
the heart all of it you are humor and
heart glenn and doyle
i can't believe i got to meet you
[Music]
you